le tourn en Z sur la RD48 à Salazie
disparaîtra dans quelques mois d'un
point de vue routier le secteur du
tournant Z présente de virage en épingle
ces épingles rendent difficile la
circulation des poids lourds et des bus
et impossible leur croisement de plus 10
km de cette route sont soumis à un
niveau fort d'exposition au phénomènes
naturel un projet d'aménagement a donc
été adopté afin de supprimer le tracé en
Z et créer une nouvelle voie d'environ
400 m en contrebas du tracé
actuel alors au-delà de l'aspect
accidentogène des deux virages où les
bus ont du mal à se croiser ou les
camions il y a également la falaise que
que l'on pourra voir où donc il y a des
chutes de pierres régulières donc
notamment sur le virage supérieur donc à
ce titre le deuxième objet de cette
nouvelle route est de d'améliorer la
protection donc contre les chutes de
pierres la protection des usagers bien
entendu avec donc une partie en gabion
sur 300 un peu plus de 300 m linéaires
et avec un écran de filet dynamique sur
les 100 m manquants alors la date de
début effectivement des travaux donc
c'est très récent donc c'est le mi-avril
15 avril pour une durée de 8 mois donc
ce qui nous emmène jusque à mi-décembre
plus tard pour réaliser ses travaux des
ouvriers résidents à Salazie ont été
recrutés
conscient des risques encourus par les
usagers de la RD48 ses habitants de
Salaz se réjouissent de la réalisation
de cette nouvelle
route ben c'est c'est bien c'est une
bonne route ben pour pour la montagne à
côté ben c'est bien il y aura une ligne
droite après c'est les gens de rouler un
peuam quoi ah ben pour salasien c'est
quand même c'est quand même bien de
travailler sur une
route dans son quartier quoi voilà pour
réaliser le nouveau tracé de la route il
est nécessaire d'utiliser des parcelles
privées les propriétaires seront donc
indemnisés monsieur Damour devra
renoncer à 3000 m² de son terrain que la
nouvelle route traversera pourtant il
est très favorable au projet bon pour
pour le tournant Z c'est une bonne chose
parce que bon déjà c'est c'est c'est des
passages difficiles pour les pour le
grand transporteur et et c'est c'est
près de la falaise aussi et comme il y a
beaucoup d' boul dans les parales ça
pose automatiquement des problèmes bah
bah une partie du terrain a été pris bon
ben moi je vois pas d'inconvénient hein
du moment qu'on qu'on me paille il y a
pas de souci hein ben cette route c'est
c'est c'est pour le bien des usagers
aussi hein et c'est pour surtout pour la
sécurité pour la sécurité parce que en
période de pluie il y a des éboulies peu
partout dans les parages donc
automatiquement c'est c'est mais en fait
c'est une bonne ch qu la partie restante
du tourn en Z sera démolie et
réhabilitée en espace naturel
végétalisé